our next guests have been um you've been
with The Hunger Games Universe for more
than a decade she's produced every
single film he's directed all except for
the very first one let's welcome Nina
Jacobson and Francis Lawrence
everybody did you I mean when you said
kind of bye at the end of the last did
you think you'd be coming back no I mean
when we made you know these movies they
were it was a joy honestly it was
incredible experience because we love
the books so much and we got so close
and so we really felt like it was over
you know it was a it was bittersweet we
felt proud and we thought we were done
and also I would say Suzanne said she
was done she' been WR working on the
books the movies for 10 years she wanted
to go off do other things yeah and four
years later she called us up out of the
blue and said guess what I'm almost done
with a new book we're like What yeah and
she wouldn't tell us what it was about
she just said 64 years before the first
stories there's one major crossover
character who we could start to piece
together who that was going to be yeah
and that there's a huge music element to
it which I love yes I mean I love the
original ones but I'm like way more and
you've got music video background as
well I we're both in music world as well
so there's a lot of like the style in
here the way you were singing Rachel
first of all so beautiful Your V
is but I love how you go it's almost
like singer songwriter Little Country
folk in there like was this all planned
that vibe that sound yeah I mean you
probably attest to this better than I
can but uh Suzanne used to be a country
music DJ yes and so it was one of those
things that she's that she's been so
immersed in that world and the the you
know District 12 geographically is North
Carolina Appalachian very Southern so
that music was very like Jug Band folksy
country music and she had a clear idea
of what she wanted all of the songs she
had actually written out the lyrics in
the book what she wanted them to sound
like she sent sent me she told me I
should look the at the Ken Burns country
document oh God it's so good and it's
amazing and it was in the pandemic so I
had a lot of time on my hands so I
watched all I think 16 hours yeah but
what I fell in love with was that era
from the 20s and the 30s with the Carter
family and with mayel Carter and all of
that and Wildwood Flower and those songs
and I think that's kind of the era that
she was really pulling from when
thinking of these ballads and these
songs that passed down through
generations and and one of the reasons
uh Rachel plays the big guitar to the
big Gibson is we were basing that off of
May Carter's guitar that she played oh I
love that everything had purpose oh
that's beautiful and then she just fit
right in and like got the tone of it all
so perfectly and then what what I will
say that was amazing is that she sang
Live every day I look that's my next
thing that is my next thing I heard that
you did sing live and you're a singer
but I just people don't get you have to
do those takes over and over and over
again like it's a lot to do that live
like and so that's incredible not
everybody I don't many people don't do
that I've never ever seen somebody do it
every take incred uh we have lots of
Hunger Games super fans in the audience
and there's one I want to point out our
assistant associate producer Olivia this
is real she actually wrote an eighth
grade paper on how The Hunger Games was
adapted from the page to the screen she
even interviewed nah for it I mean it's
crazy it really it moves me honestly and
see somebody like Olivia who was so
inspired at eth grade and then has held
on to that and and brought it with her
it really moves me it means a lot to me
I'm you know we come to it as fans but I
have a very special place in my heart
for the fans and to see people who grew
up with it and then turn out like this
is pretty exciting I got to ask you how
did you do on your report I promis I was
an A+ student I don't know what happened
I think my teacher took off a few points
and I ended up getting an A minus what
on okay here's let me see that wait a
second let me see that I love that
you're disappointed in an A minus well
I'm a little mad my mother my mother
would to thrown babies in the
air let's see where does the A minus
been holding on to
since wait a second let me get this T2
hang on a this matters more this matters
more with a circle with a circle we've
got a bunch of super fans as well in the
audience locked and loaded with
questions for all of them so we're going
to start with Rachel Rachel what do you
want to know um hi cast I'm a huge fan
of The Hunger Games I have been since
middle school in 8th grade the first
movie came out and I actually convinced
all my teachers to take our whole grade
to go see it during class um if the
Hunger Games was happening in
2023 uh who do you think would be the
sole Victor and who do you think would
be the first cannon out how do you not
say Josh after that game that win like
how do you really I would vote Josh
Victor for yeah I would vote and I would
vote myself for first
out I'm so small singing's not going to
get you very far in the games well it
gets you far in the the games yeah the
movie well I don't think that if I was
in that position my first thought would
be like to sing I got to drop got drop
some bars I got to drop some bars but
are yall competitive Hunter you're
competitive right I mean yeah I'm a
Capricorn so
I you know what I vote Hunter never
mind um thank you Rachel um and also
your outfit is super cute uh let's move
on to rendy so what's your question
rendy hello Cass hi Cy and film making
team uh Love The Hunger Games ever since
Middle School uh I did an entire
interpretive dance to safest sound to
commemorate the first movie's release my
entire Middle School body um uh I wanted
to know if uh y'all were into Hunger
Games and had to get sponsorship what
would be the natural Talent you do to
convince everyone oh well I feel like
mine's obvious cuz I do it in the movie
but I guess I'd sing I could do a tap
dance yeah you tap I I get negative
points they take money they take money
back from me I don't know what would you
do what would you I always have I always
get complimented on my whistle for some
reason he does have a really good
whistle though can you are you one of
the people that can do this thing not at
all but but I can do like a weird like
Tweety Bird like melodic whistle oh no
I've got to do it don't I
um oh you've got the V yeah it's like
some weird I don't know it's like money
money
funny so much sponsorship what about you
Hunter well I don't know I feel like I I
was going to say draw but I saw Josh's
drawing I'm out like he'd win so I don't
know now you just feel intimidated by
the art that is
Josh well obviously Josh would draw I'd
probably draw or I would like I don't
know I I uh freestyle rap uh I would
just try to find the camera and look
straight at the lens and like you know
give some looks charm the sponsor to
death see if I could just side to side I
would try everything under the sun I
don't know I'm double join I I would
move my thumb around oh yeah his thumb
is yeah wait do your arms do that too
are you double oh it's my thumb
sometimes I just it was impressive oh oh
my God you look like gumy I hate it too
I hate it on that note um okay well we
need a commercial break uh but first
I've got that grows me out but first
I've got a little surprise for everyone
here courtesy of our friends at IMAX
everyone in the audience is going home
with a pair of tickets to see The Hunger
Games The Ballad
we're going to be right back with what
I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home